across the country a growing number of
women have told Sky News they've lost
faith in the police following their own
experiences
if it happened to me again I wouldn't
report it nobody's going to believe me
if I do say something what's going to
happen to my family one of the police
officers Tom don't mean when you've got
a very active imagination for how we get
around you
Amy not her real name reported an
alleged rape and says the male police
officer investigating began to make
sexual advances towards her he suggested
he come to see her at night with a
bottle of gin even when she was living
in a women's Refuge
I was on edge yard to think what if it
does turn up like what do I if it turns
up to I have to have sex with him is he
going to make me have sex with him if if
I don't have sex with him is my case
going to get close because of it
um to me it felt like he had a lot of
power
Amy Says The Unwanted advances continued
for a year after the trial and he also
made them to a female witness eventually
police turned up at Amy's door telling
her this man was being investigated for
things he'd done to other women but the
damage was done
it's like a huge abuse of power you just
don't trust the police anymore like I
had to report an ex-partner for
um a domestic incident and I honestly
didn't want to I sat there and I said to
my sister I'm not going back to the
police but there was an incident where
he'd attacked me and the neighbors had
rang the police and the police turned up
and it was two male officers and the
mail officers asked me to come outside
and said can you come outside and speak
to us and I said absolutely nowhere am I
coming outside I'm not coming anywhere
with you on my own
when Charlotte reported her ex-partner
for alleged rape he was working for
Professional Standards which
investigates abusers in the police she
still serves in the force and says he
got the job despite a string of
complaints against him
I think to be fair the whole force was
shocked that he had a job in the
Professional Standards Department
because it was common knowledge that
he'd been investigated so many times
that's what he was known for
the force which we can't name says he
was later dismissed for gross misconduct
but despite previous allegations from
other women the crown prosecution
service in a letter to Charlotte gave
various reasons for not Prosecuting him
such as you were laughing as you told
the suspect to stop you could have
pushed him away and again he might not
have heard you say no
he might have interpreted ow in a
different way he might have believed you
too were aroused by The Hitting and it
concludes to my mind you had the freedom
to make a choice which included
reluctantly consenting it's just left me
feeling like I've been raped again but
by the justice system the people are
supposed to be looking after us it
talked about you giving reluctant
consent on a few occasions
what do you feel about that expression
it's disgusting let me put that to a
jury
Charlotte believes predatory police
officers gain confidence in the
knowledge that so few rape cases reach
Court the stigma of speaking out also
helps abusers but after seeing how
serial rapist David Carrick escaped
detection for so long more women are
deciding to break their silence Jason
Farrell Sky News
and in a statement this evening the
crown prosecution service said every
case referred to us is dealt with by a
specialist prosecutor to ensure
offenders are brought to Justice
whenever our legal test is met and to do
this fairly and with integrity and we
want to continue to encourage people to
report incidents of rape and sexual
assault to the police